for all of the history up until this
point our communication structures have
for the most part especially mass media
systems have been very top-down and
they've been controlled by a few people
that had distribution control if you
look back the church was really the
first broadcast network the church built
out a very defined architecture of
communication that was coming from a
centralized place where very few people
could have the Word of God come down to
them and they had the ability to
transcribe this was at a point when
literacy was very rare and so you had
only a few people that were literate
that could transcribe this this Holy
Word and then they were distributed out
to a local market where you had a big
impressive building that had lots of
iconography and lots of beautiful images
inside of it and the tallest building
usually in the town and they would ring
the steeple at you know 8 a.m. and we
would all congregate for mass and we
would listen to one message from one
incontrovertible truth from one source
and that's not too dissimilar from
television architecture right you have a
group of people in suits in New York or
in Los Angeles and they're deciding
what's going to be on television and
then they distribute it to those towers
and at 7:00 p.m.
primetime we aggregate around a
television that's been brought into our
home and we watch this one
incontrovertible truth in this signal
from a top-down approach and when the
internet started enabling people first
with this underlying network
architecture of tcp/ip that allowed us
to transcend time and distance that
allowed any node on the network to
contribute to the system and then we
started seeing things like video sharing
and photo sharing that allowed us all to
become publishers and then we had this
kind of now this layer of social that
has is redefining everything where every
single person is now a contributing node
on the network and every person that as
part of that uses emotions and memes and
content to
distribute things in a horizontal
fashion and so what that's doing is is
that is destroying the ability to
discern what is authentic what is not
what's real what's fake
what's commercial what's non-commercial
what sponsored what's non sponsored
what's a good idea versus a bad idea and
so when we exist in this freeform
society where every note on the network
can contribute something to the network
and it has no checks and balances if you
will there is no top-down Authority
that's editing it or or deciding what's
what's real or not
then suddenly it becomes every note on
the network's responsibility will having
to learn a pattern of behavior that we
are all responsible for the propagation
of this content because the one
interesting rule is it's very difficult
to make a mass media statement in a
cellular colonic structure noddle
network because you have to get a bunch
of people to agree to share it and agree
to propagate it no big media company can
buy their way into the system anymore
right but at the same time every if
everyone's on a balanced playing field
then people that are hackers are people
that scan the system are people that you
know kind of arbitrage the new add
features that emerge or decide to take
this path have an advantage over some of
the tried intrusive institutions you
know especially in things like the
context of fake news that's been
happening a lot you know the idea that a
bunch of Macedonian teenagers that are
arbitrage
ad dollars on Facebook system can put
hundreds of stories into a network that
people believe these fake news stories
when a New York Times or a Wall Street
Journal refuses to pay for play in a
system like Facebook and so you have
this great imbalance because we haven't
learned yet how to we haven't taught
ourselves yet how to discern what's real
and what's fake and how to look at
sources and how to you know how to how
to see them for what they are and that's
also because of a lack of transparency
we're living in these systems now that
are control
our ability to disseminate information
and we have no transparency whatsoever
when it comes to algorithms why this
content behave this way why one day when
I post something do 500 people does it
reach and the next day only five people
reaches and so until we have visibility
into that system and into these
algorithms we're gonna be at a bit of a
loss and a bit of a kind of grabbing in
the dark trying to make sense of this
new communication architecture you know
I quote Aldous Huxley who big no
paraphrase and basically says you know
the only part of the universe you can
possibly control is yourself and now
more than ever that kind of social
responsibility is is upon each one of us
right because we're now we're in a whole
onyx ystem right and you know a cellular
colonic system that we are all
responsible for the propagation of the
right information positive information
negative information fake information
you know we're all responsible for it
because we're all part of a metabolic
factor inside of the system you know the
sharing of these memes is propelled by
emotions so human emotions are the
metabolism of this system and you can
tap into human curiosity in human you
know the whole range of emotions from
you know anger - laughter - you know
desire and so we're seeing that played
out in real time right now
[Music]